[Music]  this is bomani  a marshall eagle  the largest african eagle they have  enough power in one foot to break a  human arm  as powerful as they are their strength  in numbers continues to decrease in the  wild  martial eagles weigh in at around 14  pounds with a wingspan up to eight and a  half feet  bromani is native to sub-saharan africa  preferring open woods wooded savannah  and thornbush habitats  he is an apex predator sitting at the  top of the avian food chain  unfortunately they are being persecuted  by humans  mistakenly believed to be a predatory  threat to livestock  in reality domestic animals make up a  very small percentage of their diet  add to that a shrinking habitat which  reduces prey  the marshall eagle population is  dwindling fast  this is the marshall eagle  [Music]  you